here we go you guys final day in the
oslo esports cup yeah will we see
another slip up from magnus in this game
the game has started it's a queen's pawn
opening like simon called this is mamma
darov's calling card he always tries to
control the center with white and magnus
just pushing a pawn forward getting
ready to fianchetto the black dark
square bishop will he go for the
grunfeld defense the king's indian
defense let's see what he's got in store
mamajarov just flexibly bringing out his
knight
and uh yeah magnus just
i think it all depends on the opening
for him if he chooses something really
wild and allows mama jarv to show his
quality show his uh kind of
fire or ferocity then yeah it's gonna be
an uphill struggle for the world
champion
yeah and this move i i think
with this move mama jarv probably wants
uh magnus to go into a king's indian
defense because there's two main options
that black can play here this is one of
them this is the king's indian defense
and uh well a bit of a surprising move
there from amazon just pushing the pawn
to e3 and uh you know we we're ready
yeah we're ready and there's actually
something that major has done before
very recently actually in berlin in
2022.
he's also had this exact position
earlier in the tournament and uh after
white grabbed a pawn there black's
knight coming out to the edge of the
board black is about to restore the
material balance there we go taking the
pawn back and mama jar off wow very
ambitiously pushing pawns forward
against the black knight but look at the
dark square diagonal of black's bishop
it's nearly open okay shaq had to play
this move white's bishop now on a good
square itself but this is double edged
either it's gonna be great for white
with his extra space advantage those
white pawns on the left push forward or
those pawns might be targets
and mama java actually will probably be
very familiar with this type of position
because you know he played it once in a
blitz game against uh well chess 24's
very own peter svidler ah
okay and peter svidler also an expert of
this type of setup with black especially
with where black has put the dark square
bishop in front of black's king
so how did that game end up that game
actually ended with a victory for mama
jarop but uh okay peter svidler did kind
of force white to compromise on the left
side of the board here magnus has kind
of retained some flexibility
and i think he he lost to eric hanson
wasn't it actually i think eric beat him
with the black pieces earlier on in this
tournament uh in
variations similar to this um but i mean
white has a little bit of a space
advantage you can see that white has two
pawns up the board which is nice i think
mama joroff is most effective when he
has the space advantage because you can
use that to generate an attack
and to gain the initiative it's a bit
harder to play actively when you're
cramped so i think that's that's that's
a good sign for mama jaroff but magnus
doesn't really have any weakness here
and just playing some very sensible
moves at the moment yeah maybe magnus
has been scarred by those previous
defeats against major off in last
season's tour final now he's trying to
trade off as many pieces as possible
look the night one set of knights have
gone one set of bishops have also been
traded it definitely feels like magnus
is trying to be solid uh and lock down
this game magnus if he does go to an end
game he might be the favorite uh so it's
all about whether the queens stay on and
shaq gave a check with the white queen
and the black knight went back to block
the check so small advantage for white
here because white has these pawns on
the left side and he can push them at
any moment but as simon said no
weaknesses in the carlson camp
and he's looking very car magnus a draw
for him with black is probably a good
start because he'll have the white
pieces next
so we see all the
all of uh shaq's pieces are sort of
around his king
except for for that rook but he does
have those two pawns
will those
become very important with in this game
definitely uh it might depend later on
uh once the white rooks centralize and
come to more open lines it might depend
on whether white can push the pawns
forward safely or whether black will
actually target those pawns if you
imagine the queens and the rooks may be
coming off then those white pawns on the
left side might actually be weak they
might be hard to defend but
it's just about the strength of the
major pieces here it's very very easy
for white's rooks to come to the center
look at the black crooks it's less easy
for them to find good homes
so white's king is super safe as you
mentioned black's king for now is safish
as long as it's got a night around it
and yeah it's just a well about whether
mama jarv can bring the white rooks to
the center and find a productive plan
often in these types of situations
planning is the problem uh white might
kind of set up the dream scenario
white's queen on a great square white's
knight on a great square the white rooks
will find good squares but what next
that's the big question especially if
your opponent has no weaknesses like
black's camp here um it's very hard to
find a plan
yeah and it's going to be quite
straightforward for magnus actually to
find a plan you know he's just going to
push up his pawn his deep warm one
square
move the queen to connect the rooks and
uh well try to eventually target the one
white pawn that's not supported by a
fellow pawn and that's the c4
i was i was finding these positions
though if you're playing with black you
are very cramped look at black's pieces
they're they haven't gone further than
the third rank if you look at it from
his point of view but white's got three
pieces on the on the fir on the fourth
rank and um if white generally doesn't
do anything let's just say he really
doesn't try to push
black to make progress will struggle
but i think what magnus has done which
is maybe a clever idea is swap off a
couple of pieces because when you have a
more cramped position it is advantageous
to try to make some exchanges because
you have less space to maneuver your
pieces uh so swapping some pieces off it
just makes it a bit easier uh to
maneuver and here well we see mama jar
off as david said just bringing the
rooks onto an open file and i expect the
other rook will now line up against the
queen yeah so white's rook will come to
the center as well and um just
just to talk about plans as well we've
talked about the past trading pieces now
the plans for white could involve maybe
pushing these pawns forward at some
point
on this side of the board but also white
does have the option maybe uh later if
you prepare it you can push forward in
the center maybe you have choices
and options to push forward here later
on as well just to destabilize the black
knight you're very flexible with white
meanwhile black will just kind of try
and lock things down and uh with its
last move black's getting ready to
connect his rooks as mentioned black
does have pawn breaks of his own maybe
he can push this pawn forward to
challenge white over here maybe he can
later prepare pushing in the center with
one of these pawns but it does take a
long long time and i think we'll see the
game take a slower pace for the next few
moves at least i mean
i mean there's two moves i just want to
mention if shaq is in really crazy mood
he could push that g pawn two squares he
could do
exposing his king but another thing
maybe we can just look at very quickly
uh analysis board is a very typical
looking move if you push the a pawn
right on the side of the board up two
squares this is the kind of mistake that
white can do i think it's a mistake
you're trying to make progress if you
get that pawn one square further
fantastic but if you play that black can
first of all push his pawn two squares
and then you have to do something now
with that pawn you can't guard it with
your pawn anymore and if you push it
forward again well you can see there's a
major outpost uh in the position and
that's the square there the square in
purple and white can now never cover
that square with a pawn so black has
that square under his control for the
rest of the game but okay uh shaq has
gone for a different approach here
threatening to win a pawn
yeah he's threatening to win a pawn so
after black's queen move forward shaq
has jumped into the center with his
knight and uh really ambitious there as
you mentioned simon threatening this
pawn which is actually attacked by three
of white's pieces now the white knight
and the white queen and the white rook
and if black for example pushes the pawn
to kick away this white knight i think
shaq's idea is to actually retreat to
step back and put pressure on black's
knight this time utilizing the fact that
actually the black knight is sat in a
pin on this diagonal it's getting really
tense if white can play this then he's
actually destined to
capture this black knight on the next
move for example here and he will
shatter the black pawn structure
suddenly black has doubled pawns and
isolated pawn it looks like shaq is
really creating the threats already i
was wrong i said the game would take a
slower pace but he's going for something
ambitious with this knight can i have
something so his white knight is on e5
why is f5 so much better than e5 they're
right next to each other yeah um that's
a very good question kaya i guess it's
looking at the white knight and looking
at the black king and white's knight
actually needs several moves to go and
check the black king now um so white's
knight is uh it's nicely centralized but
it can get kicked away on if you kind of
shifted it one square across that square
is covered right now but it would be
able to check the black king very very
easily um so yeah somehow e5 is never as
stable as the f5 square
is to do with pawn structures as well
it's just
it's hard to explain but yeah it's all
about getting close enough to deliver
checks to the black king white's knight
isn't able to do that in the next couple
but is it a good night now
i'm hoping it's a good night for all of
these players but that's a very good
piece in the middle of the board as well
and for the night later we hope as well
so
yeah i'm just gonna say you know
now that you guys have mentioned good
night well it's certainly gonna be such
a thrilling finish to the tournament and
uh you know to kick off the fun and also
because you really love it when everyone
at home gets involved i just wanted to
share with you some selfies i'm ready
ready and uh abby shack
says uh they're they're watching the
show but their partner in crime tonight
is
oh yes mr churchill trying to find out
how to beat this guy carlson
um simon and david will get there oh yes
oh yeah
it's a former british advert insurance
adverts great uh
and uh also tatiana flores she is
enjoying the evening with some excellent
chats and commentary and uh thank you
both for watching and of course if you
want to join in the action send us some
questions we will try and feature them
on the show and of course we do love
your selfies please tweet us using the
hashtag chessjams oh yes please do and
uh yesterday you were all tweeting who
you support who you're rooting for in
the tour finals sorry
also esports cup
and uh go ahead do that today as well
these players they need your love and
your energy on social media as well
i bet there's a lot of chakrayar fans
out there what a player yeah no
definitely everyone really admires his
creativity and the way he just comes up
with the aggressive moves because i can
tell you that there were three of us
sitting here in the studio and i don't
think any of us really thought about
this night jump at all we were kind of
considering much more positional ideas
you know improve the rooks
slowly slowly wins the game and uh shaq
is like no no no no i'm going to pose
problems from you
immediately yeah i'm not sure he's
actually threatening to win that pawn
though saying that it looked like uh
that was the idea i actually think his
main threat is the the knight move that
david uh demonstrated to actually try
and double black's pawns uh because of
course maybe we can show it quickly like
let's say black plays h5 not a stupid
move but it does weaken the black king
stops the knight coming there if you
take the pawn now
which which we said you're actually
going to walk
into a pin and i think just black puts a
rook in line with the knight and queen
if you move the knight you lose your
queen and uh you don't want to lose your
queen i've done it too many times myself
it doesn't feel good uh and you're going
to lose the knight next move so so maybe
the real threat is is actually this this
idea of uh um doubling the pawns okay
well that so magnus has just defended
the pawn
but what's he gonna do after the night
jump you pointed out there david very
good question and the evaluation bar up
in white's favor now because uh the idea
behind white's move as you mentioned
there is to simply drop back put
pressure on this black knight on this
diagonal and it's impossible now to stop
and knight takes knight uh okay it's on
the board how is magnus gonna stop this
because if he just takes the time out
now if magnus plays too slowly
too complacently then suddenly knight
takes knight and this is a terrible
position for black long term this is an
isolated pawn it will remain a target
for the rest of the game and yes the
black king is safe kind of behind this
structure but with double pawns it's not
ideal for end games either later on so
it does feel like magnus under big big
pressure after this night move
threatening to take the black knight if
the black queen steps forward defending
the knight but also threatening
checkmate along this diagonal that's
easily stopped by white's bishop coming
forward and hitting the black queen
simon you have an idea well i i the only
idea i can see behind magnus's plan is
to push the pawn in the middle of the
board two squares uh he hasn't done that
okay he's done this move we mentioned
earlier
but the difference between this and
earlier is that white can defend that
pawn uh if he so wishes i mean but first
of all just take the knight off the
board i mean you're ruining black
structure and i'm very surprised about
this because
it looks so ugly
this pawn structure for black and
i mean
what's his idea here i think magnus just
assumes that he can hold this position
and guide it towards a draw later i'm
not so sure i think you're right there
simon now white just pushes this pawn
forward maintains the integrity of these
pawns for example if we see a trade
you've got to keep them side by side so
that they cover every square and yeah
it's definitely prague uh sorry not
prague manager off with the advantage
but prague from afar will be happy to
see this position the world champion
definitely worse here definitely with
the disadvantage and we do have that
position with the knights off and black
having this kind of compromised pawn
structure wow lamijarov going for
maximum here not even defending his pawn
he's offering a queen trade if the
queens come off now then white's rook is
getting very active i'm not so sure
about that one but it's very ambitious
so we'll jump back into the position in
a moment maybe after magnus reacts and
uh yeah you mentioned it pragnanda will
be looking at this from
his computer
in the oslo esports arena but in his
first game against danish geary i'm just
noticing the bar
slightly over to anisha's side so maybe
the most happy player right now is not
pragnanda looking at his board but
liam that we see in the back there or
young christoph duda the bar is over to
judah's side in his first game against
hansen liam leah playing jordan farm
freeze today
and both liam and duda have chances to
win it i did have a quick look actually
at um
young prague's position and it certainly
seemed like a niche was very comfortable
there with the black pieces so it's
actually prague with white as well so if
he loses white there i mean it opens up
the tournament to everyone so yeah
and we should mention that all of the
four players in the top four positions
they're not facing each other so they
have their own fate in their hands in a
way they if they all win they know
they're putting pressure on the others
and uh okay some moves in this game
meanwhile the queens have indeed left
the board just as just as we predicted a
couple of moves ago and maybe to show
what did happen because things have
changed mamijarov is now one pawn up and
uh in this position the queen trade it
was just too much tension for magnus
understandably he traded off took the
queens off the board and now this pawn
is very very hard to defend so magnus
just let it go
just like the frozen song he captured a
pawn here and after the white rook took
one of the black pawns we saw a double
attack and after the bishop moved rook
takes pawn magnus though he's justifying
this one pawn loss by bringing his rook
forward and he's hoping that now the
black bishop is at least on a stable
outpost can never really get kicked away
by a white pawn and black's rooks are
going to come down and target this
lonely pawn this isolated pawn on the
edge of the board uh mama drove now
can't really lose this game but magnus
is gonna be hard to stop this plan going
for white's pawn what's the start to
this final day mom diary was thinking he
does make his move and we're gonna head
out to the lounge there's a more
birthday celebration going on today
sweater absolutely and i'm here with the
birthday boy himself it's lauren
strength happy birthday thank you thank
you very much you're also 24 like dude i
was the other day i am 24 this year
exactly that's correct yeah i know i i
look a little bit younger but that's
that's fine i'll i'll take 24. and we're
actually going to let him get by with
that one because his birthday but we're
talking about this game now and we're
seeing shaq get a little bit of a
pressing position it's
it seemed like there were two opposite
people walking in today
yeah shaq was in really good spirits
um
i guess i can say this because it's
common knowledge but he was out last
night with us uh socializing at the good
night and obviously if you're in oslo
make sure you check out great chess
themed pub
so yeah you got to get there so shaq was
in good spirits today magnus was also in
good spirits he was a little less
talkative
he had his his game face on he wants to
bring home the tournament bring home the
bacon
and you know it's going to be a very
tough match very uh different styles uh
over
you know their careers magnus has really
had a holdover shack if you look at all
the big events i mean shaq has been his
client uh for once of a better word for
many years but shaq on his day is very
very difficult and uh
looking at the position now
yeah magnus is the one who has to try
and make a draw i mean he's he's
probably gonna do it it's one of those
positions where the computer gives plus
one but
you just don't have a way to really
progress easily with white so i actually
do
think that uh
in this position magnus has got a good
chance to hold but he has to work for
the draw and it's going to be a tough
match but it was interesting what
lawrence is saying because we were out
with uh shakira yesterday and it's
really fun to hear this genius because
he is nothing short of that a pure
genius open up about his
introduction to chess his childhood how
he had to
stand up in the middle of the night go
to the park to practice his chest to get
away from a really tough background and
and and it's it's really a strong story
yeah i mean he's got an amazing story
and
uh i i've known shaq actually i played
chaka in the world
under
18 or 16 championships over 20 years ago
he's been an unbelievable talent for
just forever everybody knew he would be
a top top top player and he nearly won
the candidates tournament in 2018
i mean he was a one moment in my opinion
the favorite to actually win it and then
he would have played magnus in the world
championship finals and his ambitions
haven't stopped he he still wants to
prove that he can make the absolute top
interest um and uh
yeah it's just going to require a bit of
consistency and
he he's a way he's one of my favorite
players stylistically i see you know i
would love to be able to play like him
uh so
yeah he's gonna give magnus a tough game
today for sure and yukai you got to have
a really close talk to him uh on a
one-on-one as well didn't you
yeah
that's true that's what ivanka did in
her chess talk with mamadiara that will
be released tomorrow a very deep and
interesting talk with shakarya we're
going to talk more about that but you
did
seem a little bit surprised with his
last move david yep surprised but
impressed by majora's last move and uh
we have to jump in because drama might
be about to happen in this game it feels
like at least to me mahmoud is going to
try and take some big risks to win so
remember white is one point up it's this
extra pawn alice the airport and at the
moment this pawn is sufficiently
defended it's defended once by the
bishop once by the rook and by the other
rook but this means that all of white's
pieces are passive defending this mere
pawn and now magnus he's been bringing
his king towards the center on the last
few moves clearly his plan
okay he's changed his plan but i was
about to say his plan was to bring the
king towards this white rook to try and
trap it even but i think mahmoud here
had a sneaky plan in mind he was going
to give a check to the black king force
it to declare its intentions and after
the king moves towards the rook for sure
here mama jarv he loves to sacrifice he
was actually going to give a check with
his rook giving this rook up for the
black bishop but suddenly after the rook
is captured and white takes back look at
white's position two beautiful past
pawns here connected and also active
rook active bishop and uh this position
looked phenomenal for white therefore
magnus said okay the black king cannot
activate itself yet but if the black
king doesn't bring itself towards uh
sorry towards the white rook like this
then black is just stuck no plan and
magnus pushing pawns but that's not
really going to get him anywhere i think
the white king now is going to start
entering the game and just as i say it
mama jarv does play that move the white
king might even start shifting over uh
to protect its poor majority over on
this side of the board definitely looks
good for mamojarov right now wow
and ivanka we talked about that chess
talk
mom diero on the good night yesterday
having a good time with the opening up
about his past and when that chess talk
is released tomorrow to chess 24 premium
users
they really can get a good look into his
his past with it it's very interesting
yeah i know he's incredibly honest about
his journey you know he tells all the
stories about how he had to work super
hard how it was a struggle and in
moments and also he shares some fun
moments like
taking on players with only 20 seconds
on the clock
and i heard he was doing a bit of the
same
at the good night last night
i heard he played sorry
but i heard he played a game when he
only had 10 seconds against ferris three
he's still one
wow
but the important question is did he
play lawrence
that's what we need to know yes did he
play lawrence we need that we need the
scoop on that next time you need the
birthday boy to win some games today as
well yeah yeah out there in the lounge
yes but is he you called him a genius at
the start of the show is that sort of
his chest style he's just a genius
intuition is great
yeah i mean i remember i played him once
myself and it was in the european team
championships i was playing for england
against azerbaijan
and uh i was just amazed by him i mean
we got into quite a sharp tactical
position and he was just bang bang bang
bang bang when a normal human being
would sit there for an hour trying to
work it out he just saw everything and
it was incredible you could sort of feel
the energy and at that time
his play reminded me of something gary
kasparov would do gary kasparov was had
that sort of energy some something
special about the way he moved his
pieces and there are certainly when shaq
is on fire to something special about
the way he plays um and he can also play
these positions as well we saw him grind
out yesterday yesterday against jordan
when he needed to win in um some very
positional games he he was able to do
that so um so he's got a position that
is uh yeah going to be worrying i think
magnus somewhat here
it's interesting that you liken him to
gary kasparov both of them born in las
vegas actually oh yeah and uh okay just
a trade of pawns not too much has
changed other than that but the white
rooks do have access now white's rook in
the bottom corner which has been
slightly a sleeple game it's on a decent
square protecting some white pawns as i
mentioned but it can centralize itself
start checking the black king
i think magnus just wants to trade off
as much as possible because that might
guide him towards a draw in an end game
if all the rooks disappear white will
have an extra pawn but black will have
chances if there aren't too many pawns
left on the board
and also this black rook combined with
the black bishop eyeing up white pawns
in front of the white king
it feels to me like it should be very
good for white somehow though
yeah simon do you think or ivanka do you
think uh
magnus is going to hold this
it is a magnus type of position though
that's the one downside maybe for white
yeah it is a magnus type of position you
know we have seen magnus be absolutely
superb in the a game and
you know it's not easy for white to make
progress there's no there's no clear cut
so planned so to speak and i like what
magnus has done you know trading off a
set of pawns
on the right side and just activating
his rook
yeah
i mean magnus's bishop is so strong uh
white's got some weak pawns as well i
mean white's pawns on the queen side
yeah it's an extra pawn but they're
quite tied down but i really like
black's bishop if you compare the two
bishops black's bishop is doing uh
two jobs uh it's pointing towards two
areas of the board white's bishop is
just passive behind the pawns um so
maybe majora's gonna i mean is he
setting up this exchange sacrifice it's
a worse version now uh i would imagine
but we could show it on the board that
is he gonna play something dramatic here
let's say magnus i i don't know
plays something along the lines of h4
um maybe here you'd have to be a bit
careful well okay in the game we could
show it this actually seems very strange
because now the exchange sacrifice would
increase in value i'd imagine because of
black's room so let's see can he can he
go rook up in the actual position we're
seeing here um
and do the thing that you mentioned
david it's pretty much the same as
before yeah so this is what we call an
exchange sacrifice when you uh sacrifice
a rook for either bishop or a knight um
i'm not sure why it's called the
exchange sacrifice actually but after
bishop takes rook the idea would be to
capture back with your pawn and now
you've actually locked this black rook
out of the game these two white pawns
are connected and of course defended by
their bishop and earlier simon you
talked about how white bishop was
actually not a great piece earlier but
uh now suddenly it's on an open diagonal
white rook on an open file as well
looking great for white i think the big
question here is whether oh wow we've
seen this uh we've seen this happen on
the board the big question is whether
black can sacrifice back the exchange
giving up the black rook for a pawn and
for white's bishop and uh it's actually
level pawns here it just depends whether
white's past pawn is strong enough after
the white rook for example steps behind
and starts pushing it up the board the
one downside is maybe the black king is
just in time to go over and block it and
okay we're heading in this exact
direction we're either going to see a
draw or magnus is miscalculated most
likely though it is headed towards a
draw this is the current position and
this white pawn is very very strong but
as i mentioned the black king is in time
to stop it or the black rook can go back
and block this pawn ideally you don't
want to block with a rook rooks are
terrible blockaders but i think just
going back with the king
should be sufficient here for magnus for
example the king going back and look at
this race just in time to sit in front
of the white pawn i would like to say
just one thing i mean like uh
prague um it seems to be better he seems
to have an advantage now so i've seen
the bar swing over i've just looked at
the position and you know this could be
obviously big you know if magnus
probably going to draw this one prague
wins
but things are still building up because
you know whilst prague is maybe slightly
better and magnus is having to fight for
the draw here can tell you liam lay is
much much much better against jordan van
forest and uh chris young christophe
duda winning against eric hanson so
the heat is on and i just saw the bar
swing all the way over to giri's side oh
in prize game against uh geary that must
be a very intense game commentator's
curse as soon as i say anything what
should i say now i'll just say well i
don't know
i won't win the
lottery and so yeah
but yeah gary we did see him kind of
change position a moment ago suddenly
he's got his hand over his mouth like
he's excited um okay has he spotted it
it does look like prague has made a big
big mistake so it's not a losing mistake
by prague but giri now can get an attack
for free so okay tense tense position in
that one meanwhile liam and dude are
doing what they need to do imagine the
pressure on prague and magnus as well
yem and duda continue to win if they win
their matches in three games suddenly
pressure will be honestly yeah drama
drama drama
yeah sorry i'm sorry for putting that
tune on here
in your
yeah i'm gonna head it there all the
time yeah yeah it's just gonna be there
for the rest of the show
i mean this as david says the current
position here i think the black king is
just in time and uh you'll prob we're
probably going to see uh mass exchanges
i mean uh
i i i don't know because the white rook
can come for the f-pawn maybe the
freddie pawn it's still a bit of work to
do right yeah still a little bit of work
i kind of wrote off the position as a
draw but there's one last trick maybe in
the position that's after white okay i
was magnus shaking his head uh white
giving a check here hitting the black
king maybe he's missed this one because
uh now you have to calculate after the
black king moves forward going after the
white pawn suddenly there's a nasty
check and after king takes pawn suddenly
white's rook and white's king are closer
to these pawns than the black pieces and
we're heading in this direction very
very quickly it all uh depends on
whether the black rook can go back and
defend maybe the black rook can come
across and defend its pawn this way but
if the black rook goes back the key
question is is this holdable for black
look how far away the black king is from
its pawns it's a race the white king
will suddenly go up and i think the
white king is winning this race the
black king too far away magnus decided
nope this was too scary for black
despite the fact there's not much
material left on the board and instead
very safe move but maybe a necessary one
he's defending with his rook this one's
going to be a draw i think any moment
because the black king now at least can
gain time against the white rook and if
the black king gets towards its pawns if
it gets to this square in the center
defending everything it's a dead draw
three pawns versus three pawns no way
through
okay we did see minus raise his eyebrows
though
is he feeling the pressure or does he
feel like he's gotten away with it he's
uh bopping away now so i think he thinks
yep i have the draw
in the palm of my hands so i think he's
pretty safe three pawns versus three
pawns it's just a question of getting
the king closer to the right side as we
see duda leaving the oslo esports arena
he won his first game now to eric hansen
duda is one of the players fighting to
win the tournament
if magnus and pragnanda slips up and
duda he did have a sneaky look over at
magnus carlson's screen just as he was
walking out so duda knows if he keeps
winning big pressure now on magnus
carlsen and uh okay white's king
attacked the black rook the black rook
stepping back and mama jarv still trying
to create threats the white rook maybe
has the intention to slide across two
squares offer a trade for black's rook
and remember the black king's quite far
away so if the rooks disappear white has
some chances
maybe
what do you think about this uh because
i'm sure magnus is thinking about this
king and porn ending you know he steps
forward with the king
the rook will challenge its counterpart
on f5 and then i guess the trade happens
and the king makes a b line as quickly
as possible out we're seeing it yeah
we'll see a king and pawn end game we
might even see king versus king at the
end and this is the key move locking
white's king out look how the white king
can no longer step forward onto the
fifth rank this was the move that
secures the draw magnus stopping the
white king from advancing and now
nothing else to do you can trade a set
of pawns but you're just running out of
material a draw is
inevitable yeah it looks like yeah i
mean i was thinking white in these
positions if the black king was further
away could try pushing
his gary and harry pawns trying to
trying to create a pass pawn over there
but the black and he's gonna try that
this is his only hope uh but the problem
is the black king is just too near so
here you can try pushing the harry porn
you will get a past pawn in a king and
pawn ending having what we call here
outside passports on the outside of the
board is normally incredibly strong but
the black king here it comes just in
time to take it off the board and you
can't get a more fighting game than that
um maybe here white is a little bit
better because he has the opposition but
it's a draw yeah only the kings left on
the board first game with momodaro and
magnus and